hi reject nation Greg Alba here John is
me there's a predator that some sites
are calling trailer number two but I
think it's just a minute TV spot or
something a lot of requests have come in
for us to check out and so we say yay
two orders yeah
really quick a page from the day
shout-out for a lovely man named Matthew
beer wanted to give you a shout out here
because you're probably thinking Matt
beer
this dude can totally take on a predator
if it ever came to his jungle and he had
to kill him nap you could take him on
one on one I'm sure he'd like to say
something like that but let's face it if
there's anyone on her patreon who's a
predator it's you Matthew you are one
creepy dude I don't know why you stay
pledged to our patreon and why you're
one of our highest pledges right now
because when I get around you I'm just
like this dude's gonna do something
nasty I feel it I feel everyone gets
that vibe yeah even your mother said so
and that's why she threw you into the
river and you had to get raised by
penguins named that movie if I didn't
give it away obviously enough Batman and
Robin people I'm just kidding Matt you
know we love you dude he's gonna be
coming out here end of June and he has
his own kind of movie trivia show that
he hosts and he wants us to be on it so
keep a lookout for that little T said we
do it for you Matt we will be on it
we'll let you know when one two cred
Fred Mexico
suggest the attract spray a range of
snipers made first contact
nice it's been the driving
you showed me again I'm gonna break your
neck why I had a run-in with a space in
whoa so come and get it
[Music]
Hey
how tall was that thing look like the
orc in the first Lord of the Rings movie
oh man they're crazy let's take another
look at that big doesn't like alien
upgrade here or you see through the
other predator down scary she was like
[ __ ] what you doing to this town I am
the protector of this militant area we
crash here 1 so you start killing
everyone what's wrong you've got assess
your surroundings man he can't just be a
loose cannon all the time who do you
think we are told you to stay in the car
I gotta find this kid and I gotta get on
helmet we leave took my mask and you go
what do you mean irresponsible it's like
when somebody messes up a bit whoever's
their superiors being the crap I mean
that thing looks scary though it does
honestly I think this woman is spots
better than the whole trader yes it it
gives you what you wanted looks menacing
and scary with menacing scary it's lit
very dark it's got some of the may VP
recommend vibes still for sure I think
just if you're gonna set it in a town
like I said in a town with obviously
dark lighting here I mean you get a
better look at the cast you get some
personality in this trailer I guess
that's what especially makes it
different is just looking at the cast
and you do get personality here you see
stuff you're like this feels a little
bit more like Shane black territory just
a bit I bet those scenes in the bus
where they're all like bantering back
and I bet that's gonna be a fun scene
stuff like that it's gonna be really fun
just knowing Shane black the new
predator this upgraded thing and then
why is throwing them on the car does
raise questions of is there gonna be
some more story to explore what's going
on with that dynamic here is this
predator like protecting now ycl have
said at that predator you know or is it
just one of those things where whatever
chain of evolution has just made this
iteration the predator so much more
indiscriminately violent or whatever or
maybe they had a like a little cat fight
or they just got
annoyed at each other for a second in
the trailers maybe yeah yeah yeah he's
gonna just himself loving it like fine
yeah there's gonna get up and be like I
know I think I'm nesting I'm sorry
brother
that was cool though that was cool that
got me more excited in the last one
that's for sure yeah definitely alright
guys well yeah I mean really offer that
much too much hey that was a minute but
I hope the movie feels more like that
than the other one I hope it's a vibe of
the last trailer and this one yeah a
blend between horror and like cool
actions give that town yeah and I hope
that the 20th Century Fox logo is in
thermal vision all right guys well did
you prefer this one minutes spot over
the official trailer let us know you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell here that
chair squeaking yes and check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A as would love to have you
become a patronage act to die